- Alright, we're gonna
take a BuzzFeed quiz
to find out who we really are.
- Like which American
Idol person we really are?
- Who we really are.
- Like, maybe I am just
putting this all on for show
and truly I'm Lionel
Ritchie underneath this?
- No, you are truly
going to be Katy Perry.
- You're right.
- How about that?
- Luke wants to be me.
He wants to skin me and wear
me like next season's Versace.
- Hello?
(upbeat music)
- Choose a modern American pastime
to fill up your Sunday afternoon.
TV and chill,
watching football all day,
brunching,
scrolling through Instagram,
online shopping,
or playing video games.
Mine is brunching.
- I knew it.
(laughing)
- You didn't know where I'm going.
- Online shopping.
- Very predictable.
Watching football.
- Of course.
- All day.
- Pick a music idol whose discography
you could never give up.
Whitney Houston
Dolly Parton
Cher
Madonna
Stevie Nicks
or Janet Jackson.
- [Lionel] Wow.
- I wanna play all their songs
but honestly, I've always looked up to
Madonna.
- You might predict
that I would pick Dolly
although I love Dolly but,
I've gotta go with Miss
Jackson, if you're nasty.
- Wow.
- God, this is so difficult because I am-
- 'Cause half of them are gonna call you.
- All of them are gonna call me.
- Come on, Lionel.
- Okay, well, okay.
Whitney.
I'm in love with the girl.
- Can I pick Dolly as my second?
Thanks, bye.
- Choose a Katy Perry song that
best fits your personality.
- "Waking Up in Vegas",
"Last Friday Night",
"Hot n Cold",
"Roar",
"Swish Swish",
"Firework".
- I am definitely "Waking Up in Vegas".
- Yeah you are.
- I like that.
"Roar".
- Well, my personality for this show,
it would have to be "Swish Swish".
- "Swish Swish," okay.
Pick a snack to get you
through a long day of work.
Popcorn,
chocolate,
almonds,
pretzels,
chips,
and forget the snacks, give
me another cup of coffee.
Popcorn!
- What?
I ain't never seen you eat popcorn.
- I love popcorn, will eat it to death.
- I'm eating chips.
- Lionel, I didn't know we
shared a love of popcorn.
- Oh my gosh, you learned
something new and beautiful.
- Popcorn fanatic.
- I love it.
- You put a little caramel on it.
- Caramel!
What about Spike seasoning?
- No, no.
- Oil, I love a truffle oil.
- Ooh, that's good.
- Listen, rib dry rub on your popcorn.
- That sounds contagious.
Do you live through that?
- Lastly, choose a song
to sing at karaoke night.
"Let's Get It On" by Marvin Gaye,
"Dancing Queen" by ABBA,
"Don't Stop Believin'" by Journey,
"Friends In Low Places" by Garth Brooks,
"How Will I Know" by Whitney Houston,
or "Achy Breaky Heart" by Billy Ray Cyrus.
♪ Let's get it on ♪
- Marvin Gaye.
- I'm between two.
- Oh yes.
I'll probably do "Dancing Queen".
- I am "Don't Stop Believin'".
- Oh!
Well, I'm Katy Perry.
- And I'm Lionel Ritchie.
- You're Lionel Ritchie!
(Lionel laughs)
You're Lionel Ritchie!
I knew it!
- Because of your hilarious
and exuberant personality,
you're Lionel Ritchie.
You're rarely in a bad mood
and you know just what to say.
- Is that nuts?
Hey Lionel.
- How did I not even get myself?
- Hey Lionel, that's wonderful, man.
- Nice to meet you, Lionel.
- Good to meet you.
- Well, I picked myself
because I'm trying to be
as authentic as possible
even to a fault.
I am honest, playful and
sometimes a bit flirty.
You're the irresistible Katy Perry.
Thank you.
You have an infectious personality
that lights up any room,
not to mention you have a heart of gold.
(crying)
That's really nice.
Whoever wrote that, can they
write my bio or something?
- Nobody clicked on mine
so I don't get to see what-
- You're Luke Bryan.
You make lots of noises with your nose,
you fart under the judges' desk.
- [Lionel] Oh, I'm so sorry.
- You sometimes have brain farts.
- Do I make nose noises?
- And you've got a beer belly.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)